today county commissioners decided they
will return to
pre-pandemic guidelines in just two
weeks time joe mohler was at today's
meeting and he joins us now live from
the newsroom with more on the changes in
the timeline
joe yeah restrictions involving capacity
limits large gatherings and dancing will
be no longer being effect come june 1st
now you may remember copenhagen
mitigation plan
was originally to have counties at the
county's vaccination rate to be at 60
percent to move to fully reopen county
fully reopened that is now commissioners
decided to get rid of that plan and
instead just move forward with returning
back to normal in june regardless fully
vaccinated people no longer need to wear
a mask or
the distance this means event companies
can get back to planning
larger parties i spoke to bianca samino
earlier today who owns a photo booth and
event planning company about this news
i'm actually looking forward to working
hiring my staff back
you know being in the thrust of things
the events i love making people's their
dreams and their events come true and
their vision come to life
i'm just excited about the energy of the
city seeing las vegas come back
with the changes county commissioners
are still encouraging people to get
vaccinated and if hospitals
capacities do rise additional mitigation
may be required
in the future again this goes into
effect in about two weeks from today i'm
seeing
mixed reactions on this on social media
some think it's just too soon while
others say
why not just drop these restrictions now
reporting live in the newsroom joe
mohler 8 news now